it's just you know things happen
Jordan woods reacts to claims she never
apologized to Khloe Kardashian
after the Tristan Thompson drama but
Jordan never once has Jordan said I'm
sorry I'm sorry of course
I'm sorry and apologetic as much as I
can be in you know Kylie she provides
for her whole family off of what you
have given her and that comment made by
her former BFF Kylie Jenner's sister Kim
Jordan does not agree I definitely
worked very hard for a lot of the things
that I have and you know as you can see
I'm out here hustling and I always I've
been working I started modeling when I
was 18 and you know I work hard the 21
year old model is working hard on
designing clothes it's important to
dream big because nothing is impossible
and you have to understand that no
matter where you come from whether it's
you start here or you start here we all
have the same amount of hours in the day
and just really if you want to make
something happen just go for it
my younger self would have loved to look
in magazines and seeing the girls that
looks like me or at least were more
normal and people always ask me who my
role model is or who I look up to when
it comes to fashion there wasn't really
any girl that looked like me doing the
same thing so it's important now to try
to bring that diversity in et caught up
with Jordan at the launch of her second
design collaboration with boohoo calm
the 60 piece collection is set to launch
June 26 of the first collection which
was years ago so why not come again and
do something that is it's a win-win for
both of us very fun it's more of a
going-out collection something with a
lot of personality to wear if you
maybe I'm feeling like going out but
then you have that bomb outfit it's
gonna inspire you and it's really
there's a lot of different selection for
all different types of girls and
different body types I love body con
just because I'm a curvy girl so for me
it's like I could wear baggy on the
bottom and tie it on top or tight on the
bottom and baggy on top but we got a
senshu 8 the curve it's important to
have options for everyone growing up I
was more of I was always a bigger girl
it was hard for me to find clothing that
was cute and trendy like everyone else
and then I knew as I started branching
out and trying new things and going into
the industry myself I wanted to make
sure that I always provided options for
everyone else just thinking of my
younger self it's time to try something
new
somewhere stand out and it brings out
everyone's skin tone I'm a believer in
colors I think the color was black but
right now I'm really into the hot pink
this is one of my favorite pieces or
collections or outfits from the
collection and it's just I'm trying
something new by wearing a lot of color
because I always wear all black so I
think that color is more fun for the
summer
[Music]